you know there are still so many
questions about what happened to nia
rivera
out on lake piru well tonight e.t has
exclusive new details because only we
spoke to the captain who was in charge
of the search and rescue
we have a missing person
will we ever really know what happened
to her
in those final moments before she passed
away
well i could tell you what we do know we
have factors of wind
with the boat being pushed away from a
swimmer
we have wave action that can cause that
boat to bob up and down making it
difficult to get on
and then we have underwater hazards that
can you know snag
feet uh underneath you so imagine a
brushy tree filled area
then covered with water not far really
from where the body was found there's
actual trees it's 20
25 feet deep and there's trees sticking
out the top of the water
so it sounds like to me in many ways you
believe that boat got away from her
yeah you know we and we know was found
quite a ways away from where
she drowned and this is pretty
incredible
remember how the glee cast went to the
lake together held hands and prayed well
in those moments
a turning point
[Music]
the cast was out there when the body was
found as a matter of fact i was
i was speaking with them down at the
shore at the harbor
and uh when i was tapped on the shoulder
and and told that uh they just located
her
the captain also took nia's family on
the lake
we took him out during the search and
then when the body was recovered we also
took them out there so they could see
the exact spot where she was found
no word yet on funeral plans for naya as
the tributes continue to pour in
like never before
former glee co-star heather moore said
naya taught her how to be
a consistent and loving friend and in my
head
and she shared these photos of their
sons playing together
and former co-star dot marie jones
fought back tears today
on the talk it's hard to fathom you know
it's just oh i'm sorry but it's just
it's heartbreaking it's one of those
things you see on the news and then it's
like god bless those people
and now we're those people here to
relive
your darkest moments i can see no way
scott played coach sheldon on glee she
said she went to the lake the night
before the other glee cast members
visited to pay their respects
i went out there by myself and just
cried and prayed and talked and
told her she had to come home so we
could all rest and especially her mama
and her family
[Music]
you